[Music]
the biden administration has a long list
of metrics to make the case that the us
is enjoying the strongest economic
recovery from covet 19 in the world
low unemployment higher wages and a
record 6.4 million jobs created in 2021
one number however could erase any gains
and that's the seven percent inflation
rate
it's the highest annual increase in
inflation since 1982.
republicans are wasting no time seizing
on that fact and it's working
a year after taking over biden's
approval ratings are headed downward and
consumer confidence has sunk to the
lowest it's been in more than a decade
we looked at the metrics that best sum
up where the economy stands at the end
of biden's first year
inflation
rising prices could render any economic
gains biden has made useless the seven
percent increase in consumer prices is
already helping sabotage the president's
fdr size spending agenda
democratic senator joe manchin used
inflation as a reason to withhold
support for biden's 2 trillion domestic
spending package and in the process
struck it a fatal blow
biden touts rising wages as a signal
economic recovery but that might be a
tough sell to families who are
struggling to buy groceries or fill up
gas tanks even with a bigger paycheck
labor
the jobless rate has fallen to a number
close to what it was prior to covet 19.
before biden took office it was 6.7
percent today it's at 3.9 percent
with 10 million job openings the problem
for employers is the great resignation
four and a half million workers quit
their jobs in november pushing the
monthly quit rate to an all-time high of
3 percent up from 2.3 at the beginning
of biden's presidency
energy
the price of crude oil has gone up 62
since inauguration day to 86 dollars per
barrel the highest since 2014.
prices at the pump have nearly doubled
in the last year to three dollars and 30
cents a gallon and heating costs for
households using natural gas are
expected to be 30 higher than last
winter
[Music]
national growth
2021 gdp growth came in slightly higher
than projected at 5.7 percent
a caveat the economy's toward growth
rate has slowed since the first half of
2021 when the vaccine rollout fueled
more spending by consumers and
businesses
real gdp growth was higher than six
percent in the first two quarters of
2021 but slowed to two percent in the
third quarter with the 1.9 trillion
dollar american rescue plan not quite
providing the turbocharged democrats
were hoping for
stocks
donald trump once warned that the stock
market would crash if biden were elected
but that turned out to be nothing more
than campaign rhetoric the s p 500 is up
19 in biden's first year though the
president has been reluctant to brag
about it like his predecessor perhaps
because he knows it's mostly out of his
control
also he may not want to hold himself
responsible for the s p's 2022
performance
it's declined five percent so far in
january
bond yield
rising inflation and the promise of
higher interest rates has pushed bond
yields to their highest since before the
pandemic
the two-year treasury crossed one
percent this week after sitting at just
0.13 when biden took office and the
yield on the 10-year treasury is up 31
basis points just this month to 1.83
a narrow spread between short-term and
long-term bond yields typically signals
economic uncertainty though economists
expect the 10-year yield to continue
rising past 2 percent this year
consumer sentiment
despite the booming stock market and
strong employment americas are more
dismayed than they've been in a decade
the university of michigan's monthly
consumer sentiment survey registered a
score of 67.4 in november 2021 its
lowest since 2011.
the score was at 79 when biden took
office in january 2020 and rose in his
first few months
but inflation and surges of kofi 19
variants in a seemingly never-ending
pandemic have sent confidence spiraling
business and bankruptcies
hertz jcpenney and chesapeake energy
were among the 7 000 plus u.s companies
that filed for bankruptcy in 2020 an
eight-year high as the onset of the
pandemic upended the economy
that pace screeched to a halt in 2021
with small businesses propped up by
government spending and emergency loan
forgiveness programs
just
3724 companies filed bankruptcy claims
last year the lowest in at least four
decades according to data from the
american bankruptcy institute
belk and the national rifle association
were among the group of corporations
that went bankrupt in 2021
[Music]